what's up guys I'm Jim Gettys this is
calling Moriarty we're gonna take a look
some things you missed in the super
smash bros Cloud Strife reveal trailer
didn't see that coming what's that
coming doesn't make any sense it makes
total sense Colin here's the deal cloud
obviously known from the Nintendo
classic theatrhythm of course that's a
good more that sycamore 3df that's good
boy I wonder though if his inclusion is
final fantsy sevens Heritage's up late
it's a PlayStation game it's it's
nothing but a voice as you can uh it was
supposed to be an n64 game I think in
can you know when they were conceiving
it but it was not they were not able to
do that but I wonder if this is kind of
maybe as you suggested before kind of
telegraphing the fact that maybe an X
will also get the Final Fantasy 7 remake
that's in development we can only offer
an X in the meantime 7 reboot and then
II thought I can only interpret this as
a shot across the bow at Sony
specifically because this is the one
character people really wanted in smash
or all-stars same thing I'm good yeah
Nisshin and so they got me I know didn't
have any problems into looks like you're
getting him so cloud here never thought
I'd see the day very cool neither
neither dime exactly his look is awesome
now here's something that I really like
about smash brothers so the director of
the game Sakurai he put so much
attention to detail in all of little
things these trailers are so
meticulously crafted and even just the
character design we haven't seen cloud
look like this sense original release
yep you know we've seen him in other
forms and some people kind of like do do
little things but this I think is the
most true to the original design surely
you've seen in again the asymmetric
design it's he has a show he has like
the the shoulder guard and the gauntlet
only on his left arm he holds the buster
sword in his right arm I always really
like the asymmetrical look of him and it
was kind of I think kind of illustrative
of the fact that you had very little
equipment to deal with in Pompeii was
more about material all that happens up
so I always thought his stripped-down
look was really cool compared to some
other protagonists in earlier file fancy
him and as great as we see even already
we've heard the music iconic opening of
final fantasy 7 and we got clouds
storming in the battle the battle music
starts yeah the music or the music's
absolutely awesome so good very
nostalgic we're on a Midgar level yep so
you can see the yeah at least we saw
before the make
reactor in the background images and you
know kind of how you start the game so
as we're going through here all of these
are just as different a attacks I'm
assuming first off how else is this yes
a little throwback to fall fantasy 7
with Zelda cosplaying you get if you
will as a eris the flower girl in the in
the church so going back a bit these are
all like all the stuff we see here I'm
assuming Jose attack so this would be as
aerial forward a here that's just just
run T animations really cool Henry Lucas
aluminum fareal forward a that's
probably just a standard a attack that's
his back ere he looks at he has a triple
a combo skis a lot of speed compared to
some of the sword-wielding enemies or so
intriguing character him say in the game
that's probably his forward tilt hey
that's just the running for a day and
then that's the up air you're a huge
nerd I am and there's the one and
there's cloud punch and pac-man in it
there's the spikes of down aerial down
attack that's probably the up tilt
that's the down tilt I love the little
victory stancy yeah they're so good so
ahead in here we see his outfit from
avid children not a crazy Bobby it's
cool if they all costumes are great beat
mom mean on my point mega me which I
appreciate their see my card so now we
start to see what I'm assuming hours be
special interests so this is probably
his his side B which we know from final
fantasy 7 is one of his limit breaks
right which is called which one was this
I made the note of blade beam blade beam
it's been a long time yeah a long time
coming up on 20 years now on another one
I'm assuming that that is going to be is
standard v attack which is the cross the
cross leg
this is up be another one that is that
if a crime has returned in this club yes
yeah this is why this is bringing back I
register me I like this too this is this
is pretty cool my assumption here is
that I mean this is you know what this
is looks like he's casting a spell or
whatever this I mean I'm not part of
this character particular not the Frog
what the particular character before it
looks like a like kind of a cartoonish
version of the warrior like the warrior
class red cloak red cape or you know red
armor whatever you see it from all the
way from the original final fantasy and
then looks like you cast toad on it yeah
to terminal toad which is a classic
final fantasy yeah so interesting here
is it's the only time we really kind of
see cloud using spell I'm not sure if
because I think it's weird that toad
would be the only spell that he has sure
so maybe like every time you use it it's
a different spell kinda like pac-man
houses different moves or maybe this
just towed until kind of functions in a
way either like like toad the princess
peach uses what kind of just kind of
absorbs damage or it functions more like
Zelda's right be that sends out the the
big statue thing or it functions like
DJs little waddle Dee's right room it's
pretty cool very cute none loss yeah
little rain boulder and back to back
yeah and then here you see this now I
love this because the you know the the
limit meter for a limit breaking is is
still pixelated it looks like it's
obviously redesign for the game but it
looks like it was ripped straight out of
5 97 on ps1 which is very nice touch
definite here's where you kind of get
into some of the cooler attacks yes so
the boss music starts playing football
fantasy 7 which oh man gives me chills
now what's interesting here is I'm not
exactly sure what's going on with his
attacks I think that the limit break
functionality is similar to a little max
KO meter or show kind of switching
through the different like styling
fighting stances and stuff so i think
that the limit break is a meter that
will go as you fight right and either
when you get hit a certain amount of
times
whatever you have the different things
too we see as we go through there's
similar things that I was pointing out
earlier like though that's the same bee
attack that I was talking about oh but
just look stronger and then same thing
here right so just looks the same attack
but stronger though it's probably like
it's right B and here's his up either
giving him that's an insane recovery
right there you know I mean what you can
compare yeah it's pretty glass
ridiculous yeah I'm really just digging
watching his animations in stone then we
get to see the level which I think looks
super super awesome that's probably he's
just in intro animation coming in cuz I
thought this might have been when I
first saw the trailer I thought that it
was going to be he has multiple final
smashes right like the summons our final
smash I think I'm wrong about that I
think this is just an intro and the
final smashes are part of not the fall
semester this summons are part of the
stage right stage hazards yeah it's cool
to see them so yeah I mean so we're you
know we're starting to get through some
of them I mean this looks like Odin
domain and it's cool to see again like
kind of a modern realization of some of
these Oh some of these final fantasy 7
says all of these are classic Final
Fantasy summons generally and I just
love that it breaks the stage in half
yeah it's pretty cool which is very
reminiscent of the final fight in advent
children when cloud and sephiroth don't
want to want to kind of just destroy
this whole thing they're you able to buy
a thing i thin you have ram over there
this is Ifrit yeah so this is this is
pretty it's pretty nostalgic I don't
know I'm just looking at it it really
does make me there's a board ahamed
bahamut yeah so it's it's cool to see
more like this needs me a lot of work
going into the particular character
which is great and that's what was
thomas a keurig he really wants to like
you know pay it forward to to all these
like franchises that like kind of you
know made him the designer that he is i
just love seeing this i mean look at
Mohamed's attack in the background
coming towards the stage what's yeah
it's very cool it's really really well
done and clearly like we said a lot of
production going into this more so I
think than most of the other characters
and you know we have a lot of so I've
made fun of in the past like all the
sword-wielding kind of seeing fire
emblem characters it's definitely nice
to have you know with the addition of
shock of course it's nice to have a
character not from that series I still
fight like this now it's cool about this
here and the reasons they bring so much
attention to this face-off is that Ike
is probably the clothes
his character to how cloud would fight
you know and kind of a bigger guy with
the swords and stuff like really strong
hits but what's really cool is that
Ike's final smash is very similar to the
AMA / put some up the air and kind of
sizes him up links also is kind of that
this right here is Sakurai saying the
real Omni / is here to show you what's
up yeah so that it's great more I all
this does is just fill me with a lot of
nostalgia and filled with a lot of why
mean I'm excited to play its cloud and
smash but but it fills with a lot of
wonder of like what is the intent of
this like what the victory music right
there whoo is this is this design just a
for fanservice as this is I get for them
individually they get for them to shove
it in Sony's face is this insinuating
that NX will also get Final Fantasy 7
remake I mean I really feel like they're
this could be literally nothing or this
could be something I mean that's that
that's what's cool that's what's the
best thing about smash bros you know
it's like it's it is just a celebration
but also there's been many times the
themes of intuitive things in the future
and this hopefully we're getting some NX
love for a final fantasy 7 bigger some
wii u up who knows there's a lot of
options on the table here Michael what I
think is most important about this is
the fact that Nintendo had their the
character ballot where people can vote
and stuff we don't know if this was one
is the character than one but I do love
the fact that no one would have seen
this coming no no I know I would have
never guessed this again not because
they necessarily couldn't have gotten
him but because it doesn't really make
any sense but i think it's the reason
it's in congruent i think i'm actually
what's exciting exciting about it and
like people online i've been comparing
it to you know snake being in in smash
and you know I was like well snake had a
huge Nintendo heritage back on the NES
and then again with twin snakes so it's
not like this really is strange you know
and I am excited ladies and gentlemen
let us know in the comments what you
think if you were excited that cloud
being here and who else you wanted super
smash brothers until next time I'm Tim
Gettys this is Colin Moriarty and this
this thing's you